[Musique]
ensuite je suive le oui les cordistes et
on se trouve sur le toit de la plus
haute tour d'habitation de france c'est
la tour défense 2000 elle mesure près de
son trousseau contre 137 mètres de haut
c'est l'équivalent de 40 étages c'est ça
ouais et exactement et louis s'apprête à
descendre la face est pour laver les
vitres qui vont en avoir pour combien de
temps à peu près je pense que l'on va
voir 2h 2h30 okello bon bah je t'attends
pas très bien
[Musique]
ça c'est notre bonheur avec la même vue
de paris
avec des gants de sécurité ça c'est
hyper résistant que ce qu'il peut porter
la canche ces deux tonnes mais après
c'est vrai que avec les frottements et
tout ça c'est la roue c'est dangereux
mais sinon c'est hyper solide on n'a pas
la prime de risque parce que c'est
vraiment très sécurisé et il faut avoir
un plan de prévention pour justifier que
c'est la meilleure forme de travailler
parce que sinon un privilège
l'échafaudage ou la nacelle là on va
mettre notre armée de travail
[Musique]
comment
c'est pour ça que j'ai commencé ce
métier parce que j'ai fait faire un peu
d escalade avant d'afficher la montagne
est alors c'était pour moi normal de
chercher un métier où j'avais ce
sentiment là non c'est surtout le
sentiment de
l'adrénaline
je fais des vite parce que c'était le
métier on peut trouver plus auteurs
verticale hélas pour savoir le vide être
là en cordes suspendues
avec la vitre c'est un peu comme une
méditation tu fais un peu la répétition
des mouvements et dû rentrer ça fait
passer deux heures fait que la sa
finitude rendent même pas compte alors
là je me trouve au pied de la tour
et on peut apercevoir luis et diego qui
sont aux quarante cinquième étage ils en
ont encore pour deux bonnes heures
vous gagnez combien un salaire moyen des
bombes beaucoup
ça ne sommes pas moi m
qui voit le quotidien des gens finale
sur bien sûr trois lettres rien on peut
on mécontents venir tout ça mais bon à
la fin on dansait vite
repéré samedi dans des tirs dans un
hôtel et en attendant de les envoyer la
ville de nag quand on
a rigolé
mais arrivés dans cette cour là qu'on
est en train de descendre à la moitié le
vent a commencé à souffler il m'a fait
tourner il m'a fait très mal pris les
devants et on a fait un peu le tour de
la tôt il était amusant j'aime bien
rigoler
[Musique]